maledetto il giorno in cui ho pensato di
fare questa cosa
continua sapevo lo sapevo che mi
tagliavo ciao e benvenuto in un
nuovissimo video
siamo sempre più vicini al milione
ragazzi io non vedo l'ora
non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
cliccate sulla campanella vicino al
tasso di iscrizione e selezionando tutte
le notifiche in modo tale che ogni volta
che pubblico un nuovo video vi arrivino
notifica allora questo è un video che
non avrei mai pensato di fare perché non
ho la più pallida idea di come si
facciano sono certa che tantissime di
voi sono nella mia stessa situazione
perché ovviamente non potendo uscire di
casa e è da più di quattro settimane per
l'esattezza io sono cinque settimane che
non vado a farmi lunghe e la situazione
è attualmente questa non abbiate paura
come potete notare a parte la mano secca
perché i ragazzi mi sto lavando le mani
ogni tre secondi e quindi ho già la
pelle secca di mia figuriamoci comunque
lei crescita è veramente notevole
non mi ero mai trovato in questa
situazione bene voi direte ma mari qual
è il problema
tagliati le unghie no non funziona così
perché queste sono unghie in gel quindi
non è la mia unghia è una ricostruzione
appunto che si va a corre sopra la mia
unghia da devo sicuramente limarla e per
avere delle unghie decenti dovrei anche
insomma fare la il re film che quello
che mi fanno quando vado a farmi le
unghie cioè scoprire la ricrescita il
punto è che come ho detto all'inizio io
non so da dove iniziare perché è la
prima volta che mi trovo in questa
situazione visto che per quanto riguarda
beauty makeup eccetera eccetera sono
abbastanza fornita ho cercato in casa ed
effettivamente ho il materiale per fare
questa cosa
anche se insomma non fare un esperta e
non so come funzioni su instagram
ho chiesto insomma aiuto alle
onicotecniche che mi seguono e una
ragazza e gentilissima mi ha spiegato
passo per passo che cosa devo fare conto
è leggere i passaggi in conto poi e
farli soprattutto su se stessi ma bando
alle ciance allora io ho questa pennetta
alla quale si attaccano poi questi
diciamo punte ecco le punte sono le
punte ogni punta a una funzione non
chiedetemi quale poi ho questa rima che
150 180 ho scoperto da poco che leghi me
vengono classificati in base a quanto
grattano poi ho questo primer il
cuticole qualcosa spingi cuticole
l'eolico tecnico comunque chi si occupa
di questo è la vita si starà facendo
grazie ridate ragazzi e mettetevi nei
panni non sono un'esperta mi sto
cercando semplicemente di arrangiare poi
abbiamo il akrid acri il gel e il
fornetto come si chiama udi di lampada
uv
ovviamente questa tipologia di lavoro
non bisogna farlo se non si è esperte
perché è veramente pericolose rischioso
io ci proverò con molta molta
delicatezza perché non ho alternative
quindi mi raccomando se anche voi mente
di fare questa cosa
meglio di no se proprio dovete fatelo
con molta molta delicatezza perché
queste questa presa che gira ad alta
velocità può tagliarvi e farvi male
partiamo subito con il primo passaggio
allora la questione questa come vedete
io avevo un gel
rosa un colore rosa non bisogna far
altro che togliere ovviamente il colore
e per farlo utilizzato la lima
inizialmente poi ho voluto provare
questa qui la fresa che è un po più
difficili know quindi se siete alle
prime armi io vi consiglio la nostra
amata clima a io l'ho anche ovviamente
accorciata vedete la differenza lo
accorciata di un bel po sia per comodità
sia anche per igiene continuiamo e
togliamo lo smalto su tutte le tic a
piccola curiosità che ho scoperto
ovviamente all'ultimo minuto grazie a
voi
lei ma per fare questo tipo di lavoro a
due lati 1 che gratta di più e quindi lo
usiamo per per esempio accorciare quello
che grata di meno lo usiamo appunto per
questo per azione per togliere lo smalto
da cosa ve ne accorgete provatelo sulla
mano quello che vi sembra più più ruvido
e per tagliare quello che è più morbido
per togliere lo smalto voglia
accorciarle se l'avessi saputo sarei
fatte guarda cortissime anzi vista
risulta direttamente il cifre quando vi
dico che bisogna fare attenzione vede
ovviamente con l'anima mandò mi il
pollice mi sono sgraffignata la noc aqua
del del dito dell'indice quindi adesso
un po di alcol disinfettiamo ok allora
ho tolto lo smalto nella mano sinistra
adesso che cosa faccio con questo
aggiungi know qui vado a spingere giù le
cuticole il movimento è molto semplice
spingo giu
vedete così adesso vado a opacizzare
l'unghia con questo aggeggino qui che la
fresa mi raccomando ragazzi proprio come
sto facendo io se è la prima volta rosa
teme che alla velocità proprio più bassa
come appunto fatto io
vedete sentito il rumore così va piano e
così va forte c'è un po una differenza
quindi se non volete amputargli un dito
mi raccomando bassissimo magari fate
delle prove non so su un fazzoletto
qualcosa che avete sotto mano cioè
passata un'ora ha fatto solo una mano ma
continuiamo perché non posso andare in
giro con una mano fatta e l'altro no
quindi si continua e probabilmente farà
o no perché già solo adesso sono le 20 e
50 di sé mancano solo due ditte ragazzi
poi ce l'ho fatta cercate anche di farle
lunga uguali cioè ogni tanto mettetevi
le due dita corrispondente per ogni mano
vicine e se il caso accorciate di più
una o l'altra finito vado a levarmi nei
vari talk comunque stavo pensando che
visto che sicuramente la maggior parte
di voi non avrà questa attrezzatura a
casa ha mai estremi estremi rimedi nel
senso che una rima penso che bene o male
ce l'abbiamo tutti quanti a casa
accorciate togliete lo smalto e
piuttosto di rimanere con le unghie
lunghissime lasciatevele così il
discorso è anche se non avete il gel le
stavo guardando adesso no fi è brutto da
questa ricrescita però per mangiare
dormire e guardare la tv cioè vanno più
che bene
adesso cosa faccio con questa puntina
cui vado a togliere una delle cose che
mi dà più fastidio della ricostruzione
cioè lei crescita dell'unghia dietro
dove c'è il bianco ovviamente l'unghia
sotto ricresce e mi dà un fastidio è la
pecca l'unica pecca se come della
ricostruzione con questa punta molto
delicatamente vado a diciamo limare la
mia unghia mi raccomando non andate
troppo dentro cioè ma fate una roba
superficiale perché comunque la parte
che dà fastidio è quella che i cresce
quindi crea il gradino tra il gel e la
nostra umbria
ok adesso arriva la parte più difficile
non l'ho mai fatto non so da dove
iniziare cioè ho letto qualcosa ho visto
qualche tutorial ma tradire il fare c'è
di mezzo
cosa facciamo prima di scendere in gel
metto questo primer su tutte le unghie
il faccio asciugare all'aria allora
questo
è il pennello e questo è l'acri gel rosa
io ho una paura incredibile allora ci ho
messo bo 20 minuti sotto fare il mignolo
perché è di una consistenza pastosa cioè
che non si attacca devi andare avanti
indietro non fa come spiegarlo per
adesso solo fatto queste due come potete
vedere che sono più lucide una fatica
incredibile dovrebbe immaginare uno
smalto e cioè quella consistente questa
è come fosse nutella ecco immaginatevi
la consistenza nutella ma ancora più o
meno liquida prudenza non lo so ragazzi
in tutto ciò sono le 10 di venerdì sera
quell'ora per adesso ho fatto solo una
mano
vedete ho accorciato ho cercato di
riempire il più possibile la zona
insomma nella ricrescita più di così non
sei riuscita a fare dai per essere la
prima volta potevo fare peggio e adesso
ci sarebbe tutta l'altra mano da fare
sono le undici e mezza di sera non
ancora cenato quindi o vado avanti dice
dopo cure cenno adesso e poi non avanti
o dopo o domani mattina
ok allora ho fatto una piccola pausa per
cenare perché stavo morendo di fame e
adesso riprendo mancano in totale
quattro dita
se devo essere sincera già questo
pollice qui mi è venuto meglio
andiamo avanti voglia ciò allora
facciamo insieme l'ultima e dopodiché io
non voglio più sentire parlare di un
vedete come sto facendo da quando ho
iniziato ho capito come funziona qua la
tecnica praticamente inizio dal basso
posizione questa pallina e schiaccio in
modo da depositarla bene per poi salire
verso la punta dell'unghia diciamo ok
finito adesso limatina per cercare di
farle insomma nella lunghezza vedete già
i 2 milioni ne hanno due lunghezze
diverse quindi ovviamente devono essere
uguali
questo lo devo accorciare un po di più
ormai guarda se con il gelso prendendo
confidenza con le ali ma ormai sono
migliore amica
ok ci siamo vi faccio vedere il
risultato finale
piccola parentesi quando vado a farmi le
unghie solitamente dopo aver steso il
gel sopra vi mette uno smalto colorato
semi permanente che cambi ogni volta io
non ho uno smalto semipermanente quindi
alternativa o le lascio così tanto il
genere rosino e va bene oppure se magari
mi stufa potrei eventualmente metterci
sopra lo smalto normale perché ho
soltanto quello l'unica cosa che
differenzierà semipermanente è più
facile insomma che si che si rovini vi
terrò aggiornati
mi raccomando seguitemi sempre sia su
instagram che su tik tok perché
ovviamente pubblico dei contenuti che
qua non posso
ma bando alle ciance vi faccio vedere
come sono venute devo dire che la mano
destra mi è venuta meglio devo dire dai
come prima volta anche
[Musica]
io sono contenta la mano sinistra mi
piace un po meno perché appunto era una
sorta di prova quindi ho passato più
volte il gel e diciamo che non sono
proprio belle dice però a ragazzi come
ho detto all'inizio del video
purtroppo la situazione di emergenza e
quindi ci dobbiamo arrangiare
iscrivetevi se non l'avete ancora fatto
fatemi sapere qui sotto sempre voi siete
nella mia stessa situazione cioè avete
una ricrescita assurda e non sapete più
come fare io e le mie nuove unghiette vi
salutiamo vi mandiamo un bacione norme e
ci vediamo al prossimo video